- I'm always looking for stories
that might make you smile.
And we've got a great
one today, everybody.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(crowd applauding)
An elementary school teacher
in Charlotte, North Carolina
is helping his students embrace
what he calls socially conscious art.
Basically, he's influencing
them to observe the history
and current events that impact their lives
and interpret them creatively.
We have this awesome educator
on the line right now
watching on Charlotte CW,
let's say hi to Jamil.
What's up Jamil?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Hello, hello.
Thank you for having me on.
- Hello. It's lovely to have you.
And thank you first and
foremost for being an educator.
We really love what you do.
I think all parents really
appreciate it more now than ever
having to school our own kids
for a couple years there.
But explain more about what you mean
by socially conscious art and
how do you teach it in class?
- Well, I believe that
socially conscious art
is thought provoking and
has a deeper meaning.
And I like to teach that
way in my classroom.
I recently just taught my
students about an artist
who I love by the name of
TJ Reddy who was an artist,
a poet and activist who spread
awareness through his art
about civil rights issues.
And so, my fourth grade
students got the chance
to create self portraits in his style,
and I was so proud of them
because in the backgrounds
of their images,
they incorporated things
about the war in Ukraine,
about animal rights, about
the pandemic and homelessness.
And I just really wanted them to know
that they could use their art as a way
to spread awareness about these issues.
- Absolutely.
God, that was powerful.
Just seeing those images.
And also very therapeutic for them,
maybe if they have a hard
time talking about it,
to get it out like that.
That's incredibly smart and clever.
So, I hear that you're also a
working artist as well, right?
- I am. I am.
I am a local muralist.
I have several murals
around the Charlotte area
including one on permanent display
in Charlotte's Mint Museum.
I'm currently working on 190-foot mural
in Charlotte's Historic West End
which is historically
African-American side of town.
And I'm chronicling the
history of the corridor
by putting notable figures in the work
such as Dorothy Counts,
who was the first student
to integrate our schools
here in Charlotte.
Julius Chambers who was
a prominent attorney
who helped to desegregate our schools.
And Charles Jones who helped
to organize sit-ins in the 1960s.
So, I like to use my
art as a teaching tool.
- Wow.
- To show my students
that they, what I'm teaching in class,
I'm actually practicing in real life.
And so my students got the
chance to come out to help me
spray paint flowers into the
background of my paintings.
So, I was so excited about that.
- What an amazing, immersive
way to teach kids about art,
but also educate them on
important historical figures
that we might not be talking about.
That is so cool.
Thank you so much, Jamil.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience applauding)
- [Jamil] Thank you so much.
- And you are so talented.
And that's not all.
- Thank you.
- Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show".
They wanna honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, sir.
So, they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh wow.
(Kelly chuckling)
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- Absolutely.